Lucy Morgan was an artist.
She had spent a week painting in a small country
town and decided the next day she could move on.
She would go to a village called Kingston.
But that night, Lucy Morgan had a strange
dream.
She dreamed that she was walking up a dark
carved staircase and entered a bedroom.
It was an ordinary room except for two things;
the carpet was made up of large squares that
looked like trap doors, and each of the
windows was fastened with big nails that stuck
up out of the wood.
In her dream, Lucy Morgan went to sleep in
this bedroom.
During the night, a woman with a pale face,
black eyes, and long black hair came into
the room...
She leaned over the bed and whispered "This
is an evil place, flee while you can."
When the woman touched her arm to her hair
along, Lucy Morgan awakened from the dream with
a shriek - she lay awake the rest of the night
trembling.
Despite the little information in her story
"The Dream", part of the Scary Stories series,
the pale woman or The Pale Lady, as she'd
become known, has haunted the thoughts and
dreams of horror fans for decades, but who
is she?
Where did she come from?
In fact, where do any urban legends, folklore
and sleepover stories come from?
To find out how a legend is born a monster
walks among us, stick around to the end of
this video.
(metal music )
Welcome to Horror History.
Few series in children's literature have remained
as popular and as controversial as Alvin Schwartz's
Scary Stories To Tell In The Dark.
Inspired by Folklore, reimagined to film
and still topping banned book list to this
day, The Scary Story Series has dominated
sleepovers for decades and while the three-book
series features a full collection of frightening
short form tales, The Pale Lady of The Dream
published in Scary Stories 3: More Tales
to Chill Your Bones remains one of the most
puzzling and captivating creatures introduced
between the bleeding ink pages Scary Stories
series.
As always in Horror History, I'll be analyzing
the timeline. But the timeline of The Pale
Lady from the Scary Stories series is as mysterious
and twisted as her appearance.
So today, we're digging six feet deeper into
her origin from a Victorian dream to a living
urban legend.
Is she a monster?
Is she a spirit?
Is she right behind me?
I'll sort all this out on the other side of
the horror history screen.
(spooky music)
In the story, "The Dream", a young woman, Lucy
Morgan, receives a warning in her dream from
a woman with a pale face, black eyes, and
long black hair telling her to flee that evil
place.
After a quick huddle with her landlady, Lucy
moves to a different neighboring city, Dorset.
She rents a room that's shockingly similar
to the dark room from her dream right down
to the trap door carpet.
Convincing herself it's all cool, she answers
a knock at the door only to have The Pale
Lady from her dream enter.
Lucy understandably takes her things and flees.
To understand what's going on on that page
and a half of text, let's start at the beginning.
The author, Alvin Schwartz, first published
Scary Stories to Tell in the Dark in 1981.
Schwartz usually leaves detailed background
references and notes in the back of all three
Scary Stories books but for "The Dream", he
simply wrote "This dream is a puzzle", which
is kind of odd.
Schwartz, prior to Scary Stories was a journalist
and prone to heavy research, particularly
in folklore.
The stories included in his spine tingling
series are adaptations of tales retold around
the globe - from children raised by wolves
in Utah to cursed horses from Swiss legend
but while most of the adapted pieces in Schwartz's
books have a specific regional etymology,
The Dream is one of you adapted from a slightly
different source.
Victorians were super in to the supernatural.
Everybody had a ghost story that they really
believed and a home's haunted ghost room was
no joke.
There were classic hauntings of headless soldiers
roaming halls and knocks on doors you do not
want to answer.
Augustus Hare was a British author of many
books in the Victorian era, including a seven-volume
autobiography called The Story of My Life.
Really getting creative with the title there,
Augie...
The book recounts nights spent inside of ghost
rooms and portentous dreams which have inspired
many horror works his death in 1903, including
a few others in the Scary Stories series.
One example is "Like Cat's Eyes" - the tale
of a wife caring for her ill husband who is
frightened by the arrival of a hearse drawn
by four horses.
"The Window" is another example and Augustus
Hare's version has its own notoriety.
"Margaret found herself staring through the
window at a shrunken face like that of a mummy.
It's yellow green eyes gleamed like a cat's
eyes.
She wanted to scream but she was so frightened
that she could not make a sound.
The creature broke the window glass, unlocked
the window, and crawled inside.
It came across a room and her terror was so
great that she could not scream and it came
up to the bed and twisted its long bony fingers
into her hair and it dragged her head over
the side of the bed and - it bit her violently
in the throat."
However, "The Dream", where we first meet The
Pale Lady was not a direct retelling like
"The Window" and "Like Cat's Eyes".
It's more of a reimagining of one of the many
ghost tales included in Augustus Hare's mid
eighteen hundreds autobiography.
As the story goes, Mrs. Butler while living
in Ireland dreamt of the most enchanting house.
Years later, she and her husband moved back
to London where she began searching for a home.
Upon visiting an unusually low priced manner,
Mrs. Butler was shocked to discover that the
house was her house from her dream.
After purchasing it, they inquired as to why
the price had been so low at which point,
the agent revealed that the house was believed
to have been haunted.
Very convenient of her to disclose that after
the sale had already closed but now, they
had realized that Mrs. Butler had been the
ghost all along.
She was astral projecting in her sleep into
the house years ago.
It's an interesting concept but still pretty
far off the story that we're familiar with
from "The Dream" in Scary Stories.
There's no mention of a pale lady or a warning
or even a trap door carpet. But there is a
woman dreaming of a house and moving cities
only to end up in that very real domicile.
And though the names of the cities are different,
Kingston and Dorset, mentioned in The Dream,
are located in Britain where Mrs. Butler moved
and found her literal dream house.
Given that the tale originated from the Victorian
era, I'm going to assume that our setting
is sometime in the mid to late 1800s but let's
be honest, when we're thinking about The Pale
Lady, we're not thinking about when, we're
thinking about that face, and the appearance
of this mysterious woman has a bit of history
of its own.
[Screams]
(impact)
(eerie music)
Since Scary Stories To Tell In The
Dark was first published in 1981, the books
have been subject to banning and removal from
libraries due to their graphic content, but
any die-hard fan will tell you, it's not the
story that haunts you, it's the illustrations.
Dark and moody...
Seemingly rotting on the page, illustrator
Stephen Gammell's macabre drawings of decrepit
buildings and empty eye sockets are powerful.
So powerful that when HarperCollins reprinted
the books in 2011 with Gammell's artwork replaced
with more kid-friendly versions from Brett
Helquist, petitions to bring back the OG arts
before the reprints even hit the shelves.
Despite many chilling creatures living between
the pages of Scary Stories, The Pale Lady
has become the most well-remembered image
from the hair raising series, beloved by horror
fans and probably burned into the memories
of innocent children browsing their local library.
The actual words of "The Dream" give a very
basic description of her black eyes and hair
but the accompanying illustration creates
a whole other dimension.
Many of Gammell's illustrations featured in
Scary Stories are ghastly but The Pale Lady's
expression has been described as benevolent
which is supported by her role in the story
of warning off Lucy from the room.
Stephen Gammell has never spoken at length
about his work in Scary Stories but commented
about illustrating work in general.
"The first time I read a manuscript, I can
immediately tell whether I want to illustrate it.
I may not know how the illustrations will
look but I get a certain feeling for the text.
I respond to the words and if I can respond
to a story, I can illustrate it."
Meaning that the illustrated design of The
Pale Lady is entirely inspired by the written
word of The Dream and not an outside source.
The original source from Augustus Hare doesn't
mention a pale lady or pale woman anywhere
in the text, nor does Alvin Schwartz reimagining
and Scary Stories offer many specific descriptors
of her character beyond a very simple physical
description.
The impression of The Pale Lady is entirely
based on our own interpretation.
It's no secret that most of the short stories
featured in Scary Stories To Tell In The Dark
are common urban legends such as The Hook
but The Dream truly embraces the spirit of
an urban legend by coming to life more and
more with each retelling and in the 2019 film
adaptation, Scary Stories To Tell In The Dark,
The Pale Lady was written out of the illustration
and into another reality.
– What's that?
– [Stella] I can't believe it.
It's her book of scary stories.
– [Zac] The screenplay as adapted by Dan and Kevin
Hageman from a story by producer Guillermo
del Toro who is no stranger to Victorian horror
follows a group of misfit teens who open a
book that they shouldn't have opened and release
the creatures of Scary Stories To Tell In
The Dark into the real world.
An ironically similar concept is the film
adaptation for its fellow children's horror
literature juggernaut Goosebumps.
To be fair to the Scary Stories film, it's
pretty gnarly, just as with the books, while
the Goosebumps film generally stayed in its
lane of kid horror, Scary Stories To Tell
In The Dark does not shy away from body horror,
light gore, and some Victorian haunt sentiments,
as one would hope and expect.
– Our friend is a little nosy.
– In most cases where a book is adapted to the
screen, the book is considered canon and I
stick to that when analyzing the timeline
but with The Pale Lady, given its nature and
continuously evolving legend, we can consider
the film to be more of a continuation of her
legend.
As noted, we surmise the events of the dream
are happening in Britain most likely during
the Victorian age in the mid to late 1800s while the events of the film occur
in 1968, in the US State of Pennsylvania.
So it could be said that The Pale Lady first
appeared in Britain then reappeared in the
small town of Mill Valley, Pennsylvania in
1968 after being unleashed from the book.
I assume the book that the kids find in the
movie would be similar in content to the Scary
Story trilogy in our world.
Only in the film, the book was not written
by Alvin Schwartz but by Sarah Bellows, a
young girl locked in a basement by her family
at an undisclosed time in the past.
– [Stella] Sarah Bellows had a secret, a daughter that
they never allowed to leave the house.
The myth is that there was some really off
about her.
– In her imprisonment, she wrote scary stories
that she would recite to kids listening on
the other side of her wall.
– And though they never saw her, they could
hear her through the wall.
Sarah told them stories… scary stories.
– So of course, they take the book which begins
to write stories all by itself.
I hope when I die, I leave behind a book that
just writes horror history scripts but I'll
probably just get the same thing that the
heroes of Scary Stories To Tell In The Dark
got - stories about a murderous scarecrow,
a corpse toe, a jangly man, an infected cheek,
and a pale woman - stories that come alive.
Each story rather than being a stand-alone
tale is related to a specific teenager's fear
or just something that annoys them including
The Pale Lady.
In this case, Chuck, one of our four teenage
victims, I mean, heroes, recounts a recurring
nightmare to his friends describing someone
who sounds very familiar.
– I had this messed up dream again.
I was trapped in the red room and there's
that fat pale lady keeps whispering 'This
is the evil place, run away while you still
can.
– Soon after, the kids take a field trip to
a hospital looking for answers, like one does
in a horror movie.
There, Chuck separates from the group, which
is never a good idea, and wanders off to another
building on the grounds.
He finds himself in a series of empty hallways
as the hospital alarm goes off and the light
turns red and she appears - pale face, black
eyes, wide thin smile - The Pale Lady.
(siren)
(impact)
(eerie music)
In this adaptation, The Pale Lady is considered
by fans to be the most faithful representation
of a character from the book.
The main difference is the ability to see
her feet, bare and pillowy as the rest
of her, and a nightgown that seems to melt
into her skin.
You can't determine where she begins and the
fabric ends.
Despite Chuck's dream, The Pale Lady doesn't
speak beyond unearthly murmurs as she shuffles
slowly towards him.
Appearing in every hallway before cornering
him in the center, The Pale Lady gives Chuck
a deep hug pulling him into her body with
a satisfied smile and she disappears.
– [Stella] Chuck and Auggie are still gone but I know
there is a way to bring them back and that
the secret is in the book and we won't stop
until we find them.
– Until the unpleasantness with Chuck, The Pale
Lady hadn't been considered an antagonist
and she still might not be.
She was only trying to warn Lucy about the
danger of the house in that short story and
until we know where Chuck disappears to in
the movie, I can't definitively say that The
Pale Lady is evil.
Perhaps with the spirit of Sarah Bellows stirring
the pot, The Pale Lady was trying to save
Chuck in her own way by taking him to a realm
where he'd be safe.
But Sarah Bellows' inclusion does complicate
things.
Alvin Schwartz's work was openly based and
adapted from folklore and other tales but
within the world of the film, the spirit of
Sarah Bellows is writing these stories in
real time.
That would imply that the urban legend, "The
Dream", never existed in the movie universe
unless of course, Sarah is writing new lore
for a character from an existing legend.
– You don't read the book, the book reads you.
– At the beginning of this video, I mentioned
that there were two other tales and Scary
Stories inspired by the accounts included
in the autobiography of Augustus Hare, "The
Window" and "Like Cat's Eyes".
Both of these stories are almost direct lifts
from their source material with the same beats,
same characters, and even some word-for-word
dialogue.
– Stories hurt.
Stories heal.
– So in this case, we're not analyzing her timeline,
we're building it, making her more real each
time we do so, starting in the mid-1800s with
the story of a woman who allegedly dreamt
of a home that was proven real.
Her tale was preserved within the autobiography
of Augustus Hare in 1859.
Then in 1991, Alvin Schwartz publishes Scary
Stories 3: More Tales to Chill Your Bones,
including the short story, The Dream which
introduces a character who would become known
as The Pale Lady.
In 2019, the film adaptation, Scary Stories
To Tell In The Dark reintroduces The Pale
Lady in the year 1968, first is a dream and
then as a walking physical creature to audiences
new and old.
– Stories hurt.
Stories heal
If we repeat them often enough, they become
real.
They have that power.
They make us who we are.
– Who is The Pale Lady?
An urban legend that grows more visceral with
each retelling of the story.
Who knows when we'll meet next.
Let me know if there are any other scary stories
characters you'd like to see covered here
on Horror History.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week.
Ring the death bell and select all notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.